make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay for 25 years just about maybe give
or take a year six months seven months
something like that I've been reading
the x-men and what Jonathan Hickman has
done in this second issue is make one of
the single biggest changes to the x-men
mythos than I think I've ever seen to be
honest it's one of the funny things the
Axman mythos doesn't really change right
I mean it never really changes a lot
often like it's usually just kind of the
thing I like mutants are persecuted
humans want to get them and then they
gotta fight for their lives and then on
to the next volume that's basically you
know that the form and function their
stories follow however what Jonathan
Hickman has done here is change the
mythos of mutants who can reincarnate
which is to say they can live forever
and he does this by way of a character
named Maura McTaggart now this is why
this is so huge we've talked about Maura
McTaggart multiple times right the idea
that she was just a mutant geneticist
she was a person who would study
meetin's powers if Charles Xavier
couldn't figure it out or if she
discovered them on her own and then she
and Charles Xavier would work together
to basically craft a kind of training
program for how those mutants would
function and and so on and so forth what
we end up learning here is that Maura
McTaggart has lived over and over and
over again she's actually lived a total
of ten laws she's died and then been
reincarnated in multiple times and it's
kind of the crazy thing because that's
her mutant power and that's why that's
so huge is because more McTaggart was
never a mutant she was just a normal
human with just the ability to
understand mutation and so on and so
forth she never had anything special
about her one of the first things that
we learned her at least one of the first
things that he tells us is that in her
younger years more McTaggart when she
was around 13 years old or so developed
fever now we're not really given an
exact timeframe here we're kind of left
to believe that it was in like the very
early days of not really the early days
but maybe like a hundred years ago or
something along those lines
but basically she fell ill and then she
was supposed to have died now the result
is that she actually woke up and she was
white right as rain the next day and the
reason why is because presumably her
mutant power manifested now how that
affects reincarnation is not explicitly
given to us but what it does seem to
indicate is tried and true immortality
to a degree where at least a slowed
aging process the issue with that with
that theory with that idea is that she
grew old and she died it's kind of hard
to argue immortality when you pass
peacefully in your sleep at 74 years old
you can't really you can't really argue
immortality in that circumstance because
then you're not immortal but when that
happens she was born again the cool
thing about this is that when she was
when she was conceived when she was
reborn
she basically ended up remembering
everything from her past life now
Hickman is a bit ambiguous about this
and one of the things he doesn't answer
is how is it that she's reborn is she
reborn to other parents or if she reborn
through the same parents and just kind
of living the same life over and over
again the idea seems to be that she's
just reborn but in a different body
every single time and that's one of the
things that he clarifies almost
immediately right so she's born and then
she comes out in an in a totally
different form than the way she looked
when she was younger now along the way
in her life more McTaggart eventually
encountered Charles Xavier not directly
she had simply just heard of him now the
cool thing about this is that Hickman
doesn't really go as far as to say more
make Hagrid is the reason why Charles
Xavier is the way he is
she was really more of like a silent
observer for a long time when he first
got his name out there but until Hickman
comes along and changes things we can
largely assume the life and times of
Charles Xavier are still the same and so
because of that it's kind of funny
because the way that Hickman describes
it when Professor X got on TV and
basically said hey look here's what's
going on out there and there are mutants
out there there are people with powers
and so on and so forth this is tying in
directly to Charles Xavier Xevious
actions of like admitting that he was a
mutant on national television which was
kind of a big deal when it happened but
the overall tone she got from Xavier in
his early years is that he was arrogant
that he was a person who was overly
confident that he was kind of a dick and
so it was interesting because she didn't
really see you know looking at her own
life and how it functioned she didn't
really see professor X's message of
mutants being the next stage of human
evolution and having powers is a
blessing and you know they're gifts and
so on and so forth she don't really saw
it like that instead she saw it more as
a curse and so the result was that more
mage Hagrid's eventually developed a
cure for the mutant gene she
successfully developed a way to
eliminate mutations now what this did is
it led to the intervention of mystique
and destiny now a lot of the guys who
were new to the x-men probably don't
know who destiny is and that makes sense
she as far as I'm aware I mean I think
she's come back recently but there was
like a twenty maybe thirty year gap in
Marvel Comics where she just wasn't
there
destiny was really and all even if it
was really hinted out so much as an
absolute thing but destiny was the love
interest of mystique and eventually
destiny was killed off by Legion I think
it was and then that was the reason why
mystique went to go kill Legion Legion
woke up out of a coma that kicks off
Legion quest which goes into Age of
Apocalypse but the idea behind
this was that destiny had the ability to
see into the future right she was a
Precog now it wasn't really in so far is
this like these are gonna be the winning
lottery numbers for tomorrow it was it
was one of these things where it's like
a conflict is coming later on down the
line she really seemed more like a
serous or like a like a religious figure
you know in terms of how her powers
function and how they were depicted in
Marvel Comics as opposed just kind of
being like make sure you go left when
you get to the fork in the road
otherwise you're gonna crash into a
truck and dot yeah it was interesting
the way that it worked but for a long
time mystique and destiny were in
separable there was a one-two punch of
of the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants in a
lot of ways the x-men's villain group
now there was kind of a cool thing
called Destiny's Diaries right like
after destiny died there are all these
Diaries that she had where she had
written out things that were going to
happen and it was like the hunt for
Destiny's Diaries it's a really really
cool set of events in Marvel but
essentially what seems to have happened
here is that destiny you know had a
vision of sorts of more McTaggart and
the future that her her discovery would
lead to right the future would lead to
in terms of discovering a gene or I
guess a formula that could cure the
mutant gene the result is that destiny
says what you've done here is set in
motion a series of events that will lead
to a war that will lead to the
destruction of all things and that's why
the Brotherhood is here right because
what more I Tigers done here she's
basically laid in motion a set of events
that's going to lead to the destruction
of all the mutants and so the
Brotherhood basically consisted of
mystique and destiny pyro and I don't
think there's anybody else I don't think
Avila no avalanches there so this is
back in the 1980s presumably during the
second iteration of the Brotherhood of
Evil Mutants that what they've done what
they do is they basically say like we're
going to kill you like we're going to
destroy you and we're gonna destroy your
cure and then you're gonna you know
you're gonna die and you're gonna be
reborn right because destiny knows about
all this she's a Precog but she's like
you're gonna die and are gonna be reborn
and then take this knowledge into the
future and know that if you do this
again it'll lead to the destruction of
everything and so one of the things I
actually end up doing is burning her
alive right and like doing it slowly so
she just kind of has time to think about
what it means to truly die and so the
result is that when that happens when
she when she goes forward the formula is
still there she still creates it but
doesn't advertise it she doesn't go out
and tell anything instead what she does
is actually start growing closer to
Charles Xavier
she starts focusing on what it is that
he's looking for and so this is really
kind of changing the history of it all
right so like Neal chronologically you
go through the entire lifespan or the
entire time
that Maura McTaggart has been in the
x-men comics originally all you got was
me oh boy meets girl boy
girl fall in love and then eventually
they break up that was basically what it
was in terms of Maura and and Xavier
what Hickman's doing here this coming
back and changing everything and saying
somewhere along the line more McTaggart
was born and then she did some things
and then she died and that she was
reborn and she did some things and she
died didn't she was reborn and then she
met Charles Xavier and that kind of
picks up with the modern era you know if
you go if you if you start with Chris
Claremont and you go through with more
make a grinning all the things that he
did with her then what you blue you
essentially are looking at is the third
life of Maura McTaggart in Marvel Comics
it's cool and that's one of the things
that Hickman highlights he says like she
was there by his side when the original
x-men were formed when the Giants eyes
and the new launch of x-men was formed
when you were talking about X New
Avengers vs. x-men and the death of
Xavier himself and then this future that
destiny said would come to pass when the
humans would eradicate the entirety of
the mutant population this really seemed
more akin to like Days of Future past
but still the deaths of all these
mutants at the hands of humans and then
eventually Sentinels and so really using
this life experience she has she tells
Xavier read my mind and see this future
that awaits us see what happens with
these things that I do and where she did
she eventually achieves Xavier stream by
kind of having this biodome the various
mutants reside in that cuts itself off
from the rest of the world manage hacks
yet again a war breaks out and then all
the mutants die and so the result is
that what she does is she looks at that
and she says okay so basically this is
all the fault of all of our Trask
now again a little bit of history here
all of our trash was introduced in
Marvel Comics as part of Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby's run on the x-men and the
idea was that he was the first one to
create the Sentinels write these giant
robots that would serve the purpose of
whatever their makers wanted following
ball of our Trask in his defeat and
presumed death at the time although I
believe he ended up coming back well you
got with Stephen Lang and Stephen laying
those are the Sentinels the x-men were
fighting that was the prelude to the
events of the Phoenix and the Dark
Phoenix saga and really like a lot of
the signals that came after now there
were various people who invented them
after that but more McTaggart realized
that the entire Sentinel program which
is to say these giant robots being
controlled by man set on the on the
course of killing mutants was all done
at the hands of all of our Trask she
goes through and kills every single
member of the trash family so that
hopefully none of this will come to pass
the result is that all of it does anyway
that at the end of the day humanity by
for whatever man and whatever means was
hell-bent on creating sentinels and that
leads to everything that kind of took
place and so what this does is point to
the idea that a war between humans and
mutants
that it's going to happen and the reason
why is be is the same reason that those
conflicts have always broken out and
that's one of the things I love about
what Hickman's doing he's introducing
new things but kind of saying all this
has happened before and all of it will
happen again the entire idea behind
Beverly Stanley and Jack Kirby's x-men
so much is Roy Thomas Arnold Drake and
then eventually Chris Claremont going
into like Jim Lee's Scott Liddell Grant
Morrison Chuck Austin the whole idea
behind like the writings of these
characters and the the nature of the
x-men is the x-men represent humanity in
its current form being removed and
replaced by something better and what it
does is it instills fear in humanity as
it exists now right because while they
don't really rationalize it in the sense
of I will achieve a higher state of
being they rationalize it in the sense
of everything that we know will change
and it will go away right like it's an
inherent fear of change and because of
that fear and not really being able
being able to understand the mutant
population they in turn lash out against
them now other things sort of feed into
that the notion that like mutant powers
manifest and there's no real way to know
what kind of form they're going to take
right so like some six-year-old kid
sitting in his class and it suddenly
sucks the oxygen out of the entire room
because his powers kick off because he's
been bullied and he goes into a
heightened state of stress or some girl
is like 13 years old she starts going
through puberty and then like lets off a
massive explosion and eradicate slike
half the United States like there's no
way to know if that's what's going to
happen that's one of the other things
that people are fearful about is there's
no way to be able to check engage what
kind of powers a person is going to have
it's random it's arbitrary there's no
real way to know and so again there's a
lot of fear factors that go into into
the human perception of mutants and why
it is that they're so angry and so
because of this what more McTaggart does
and she basically size yourself with
magneto and she looks at this she says
okay so Charles Xavier has this idea of
a peaceful coexistence but that won't
work because Charles Xavier doesn't have
the balls to do what needs to be done in
the face of such hate and such such
anger he believes you can just talk
people into doing the right thing when
they won't magneto is more heavy-handed
hey if they don't want to correct their
act then all correct it for them and
that's what she does she goes along with
him and basically says like here's
everything that's going to happen here's
how this world is going to unfold
magneto lashes out loses it launches an
attack by firing firing like nuclear
missiles at the White House
and the entirety of the x-men and the
Avengers and the various superheroes
Fantastic Four The Incredible Hulk and
so on all team up against magneto and
they all defeat him so that that is yet
again another circumstance
each one of these defeats each one of
these scenarios where she sort of goes
down a different path
it's her having died somewhere along the
line being reborn and trying to correct
her mistake and so following disc then
she basically goes along and says okay
fine if the dream of Charles Xavier
doesn't work if the actions of Magneto
don't work then what we need is a mutant
with overwhelming force lead a mutant
with just an insane amount of power an
overwhelming amount of power they can
essentially crush everything in its path
that anything that comes its way will be
incinerated destroyed and and that'll be
the end of that what she does is she
allies herself with the villain
apocalypse and this is one of the
coolest things right because apocalypse
is a being of Darwinism these social
Darwinism only the strong deserve to
survive the weak will make way for the
strong it's the natural order of things
now here's the important thing to
understand what a hitman kind of says
here is like in this war that broke out
between humans and mutants this conflict
as it takes place in this timeline of
this life that she's lived instead of
humans making the first move
it was apocalypse who made the first
move it was more a McTaggart going to
ensue bond newer and saying hey look
here's how everything is going to unfold
here's everything that's gonna happen
here's all the things that I've tried I
need your help now and then apocalypse
was more like okay so if what humans
want is a war with mutant kind then we
will bring them award we will give them
a war without end we will test them
endlessly like we will constantly put
them in a situation where they're going
to have to do whatever it is they need
to do in order to win the danger in that
is that it basically produces a scenario
where apocalypse himself can be
destroyed and that's kind of what he's
looking for right it's kind of looking
for a scenario where like only the
strongest survive even if that means
that he becomes weak that means that he
becomes obsolete now he would have to
adapt and have to thrive in the face of
that but what you end up getting here is
in in the outset of this first conflict
when it when it all kind of came about
in apocalypse and his four horsemen face
off against humanity they wiped them out
on every level everywhere they went
right like they killed all the
superheroes they've wiped out every
major city in the United States and what
you had was what was left of humanity
banded together and then facing off
against them it created a whole new
level of sentinels a whole new level of
machines and none of it worked
none of it worked at all at the end of
the day apocalypse just like so many
other villains before him so many other
mutants before him ended up falling and
ended up dying and more on McTaggart was
reborn
yet again and so what this does is this
wraps us back around to the modern day
so the beginning of house of x-- number
one and so what this seems to indicate
is that this is the eleventh life
more McTaggart it's the 11th time that
she's gone to Charles Xavier it's the
11th time that she's tried to find a way
to see if there's some kind of balance
that can be struck between humans and
mutants it's the 11th time that she's
gone down the path of presumably leading
to a future where mutants and humans
will go to war and all the mutants will
be destroyed it's the 11th time she's
done this and like the 10 times before
it she's trying to find a way to see if
it's possible to make it work with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later Bruce
[Music]
you